now since you asked about my kind of  canned thing that I tend to say that the  other thing I like to point out when  people ask about experience is that I  have more government experience than the  president United States that's such a  low bar and if you think that's a little  more I also have more executive  government experience under my belt than  the vice president of the United States  and more military experience than  anybody to walk into that office since  George HW Bush so as cheeky as it is as  the 37 year old youngest guy in the  conversation my simplest answer to the  question of why somebody like me  deserves to have a voice in this  conversation is experience